[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on everyone this is charity
fry I just want to say hey thank you for
joining us I'll run it back this week
this month we're joined by two and
three-time NBA champions Dwyane Wade and
UD guys to the 2013 Miami Heat team and
this is where we're gonna be watching
today thanks for joining me
obviously ok here is Mike but some fun
facts about Yugi is that he had three
years of tap and jazz at the Miami high
school and he Dewayne Wade at Heron
Richards won the chili cook-off two
years in a row so we're glad that
they're here to go over this season
having a good old time I can't wait for
this to get stud this is a roast on D
way right that's what we doing we roast
and listen we're gonna get to that we're
gonna get to that I came to see you
listen just just listen to this voice of
reason and we're gonna get to watch it
all the highlights of that amazing
season in 2013 we're gonna get to good
the bad the exciting the great but y'all
too since you can hear me at least tell
me about the chemistry of that 2013 team
glad we can y'all see each other no
because I don't like the fact that I
feel like I can't thank you I appreciate
that man it was for both of us you it
wasn't a question for me
I told you to go first though you didn't
say nothing as soon as I found an answer
now you want to say something now go
this tells about brothers y'all argue
like brothers so I guess he was not my
video man I guess it was you know coming
in from obviously not being able to get
it done you know
the year before and did we come in and
win it but we always remembered that
first year where we wasn't able to get
it done we always stay hungry for that
because we always understood that first
year we really understood that how many
people was really against us we really
created that us I guess to where I'm
gonna tell you that first year and when
we didn't get it done it I kind of
carried us all the way through our ride
towards the end it got a little rocky
you know what I'm saying but you know
that really cares for the first couple
years having that us against the world
mentality you know how that is where you
got you know just us guys in this locker
room and nothing else matters do you
think that was the LeBron effect or
having the big three you know quote
unquote or is that like a Miami thing
because everyone talks about the Miami
culture and how you guys are of like you
just do things differently you do it the
miami way that a LeBron or is it a it's
it is it it like a LeBron or superstar
thing you know it's probably Brahma
because he just came with his decision
came with so much criticism you know you
know so many people wanted to nitpick
about how he did it or you know what the
decision was made or how he presented it
or whatever so you know for us he
understood that he was coming in with a
lot of baggage so we just wanted to
surround him with family let him know
first and foremost we got you you know
I'm saying when you come in here you and
this locker room you part of us you one
of us we carry your burdens we carry you
you know I'm saying everything that come
with you your enemy is my enemy
your burden is my bird and you know
that's the Brotherhood that we have in
this locker room in Miami so you know
when people talk about the culture
before you even get to the coaching we
create a brotherhood you know saying
you're one of us when you walk through
that locker room that's amazing I felt
that way when I got traded to Cleveland
and so just hearing that from you and
and seeing all the years you were there
to kind of transition to the court I
felt like that 2013 team even though
offensively you guys scored your
ffensive
y'all were some monsters right y'all
Jason we're getting out transition
physical is that something that you've
seen keep going throughout the years
that you played there or was that a
special special team in a special year I
mean we always focus on defense you know
our defensive philosophy is always you
know been top-notch but we always focus
on defense but when you put super
athletes like LeBron James
Chris Bosh the way any way was outright
athlete you put guys like that you put
guys like that in the system you know
what I'm saying you put athletic guys in
the system and guys get to flying around
and the system becomes second nature and
you know just as well as I do when you
got everybody on the same page and guys
are having fun and flying around and
guys to motivate it you know I'm saying
it's like being me like kids when it's
all when everybody on the same page
homework or yeah we'll see these
highlights whenever they come here all
these dunks are literally steals oh yeah
obstacles Leu it was just I mean I
remember being I think I was in Phoenix
in 2013 and you guys just get down
passing lanes and the speed between
throwing three or four different guys of
six seven six eight Shane Battier Mike
Miller Bronte Wade you know Chris Bosh
is just a lot first and foremost there
was only two people that got layups on a
break on that team
Bronte wait they literally push down to
run the break on to get don't even know
Rana Rana a so foot it from the break
like you know Chima no thanks yeah when
we get a steal everybody already knew
what time a wood man ain't nobody got
time to be get knocked out on the plate
at a team in no way involved in try to
get in front of Brian on the break so I
got a fan question here
Adonis who was your best teammate you've
ever played with oh man now I gotta say
it cuz he owned you
oh he weighed over shout a mile here
dawg we can hear you bro nothing my best
teammate I would say D way man just
because we came in
you know I'm saying Shaq was always
already established Mandy Waite came in
together man we literally spent the
entire summer together this man has so
many damn cavities when I met this man I
felt inclined to help that kid from
Chicago just do this whole dental
history out there I was like man I get
you know what I got you I got you yeah
so just to keep going about that season
Birdman had established himself as a
really good player right as a really
good energy guy but when he got to Miami
I saw something he became a different
beast entirely did you see that from the
beginning or again is that like a
culture thing is that a Miami thing man
he was the perfect piece to our puzzle
you know and it was part of the partly
the culture because when bird got in we
actually spent about two three weeks
working a man conditioning rising and
getting them on a level that we needed
him to play you know Miami Heat
conditioned in my need level so it was
partly you know part of what we do here
in Miami but also the character of Burt
you know whoo yeah yeah you know what he
represents great you know the city
embraced the city embraced in the locker
room embraced him and before you know it
he was probably the most popular guy on
the team next to you know the big three
guys you know I'm saying so yeah where
is my bash bro man we always talk about
that we don't do WWE or retire so where
did you listen to Brian gave up on that
we still get in that ring bill yeah
listen I I was you know we're gonna get
to all this what's d-wade comes back
with you guys is bench really is is the
part that took over the games you know
obviously Chris Bosh and D blade and
brawn we're like big three but once one
of them went to go sit down you guys are
bringing in championship caliber guys
off the bench was that a I remember
obviously me coming off the bench in
2016 and choice 17 going to finals but
did you guys feel like your bench was
almost better than most starting teams
oh for sure
man we sometimes we thought our bench
was better than the big three they was
it was I mean but the little man listen
here people underestimate the impact
that a little 12 man I'll tell you man a
little 12 we're strong man a little 12
were strong bro shout out to Mike Miller
Jay
de ray Rashad Oh everybody notice what I
don't know what it is man man listen
yeah I mean Mike Miller is a solid vet
one of the best shooters I've seen then
you have Ray Alex are the best shooters
ever if not the best in there and then
you go to shame Betty and we'll see this
later on as I say a lot he was 6 for 8
right off the bat because in game 7 and
so for me I'm like for those vets to
come in and contribute right and take
that pressure off of Chris Bosh who I
remember I was going through summer
workouts and Bosh a lot of people forget
he didn't scored a game but if you watch
him he was exhausted trying to play Tim
Duncan straight up one-on-one and I mean
that type of credit and that type of
guys stepping up for you Mario Chalmers
stepping up Norris Cole stepping up you
had a bunch of guys doing great things
so just talk about like just what they
had was it because they did bench step
up because of your success during a
regular season or did they just know
this is time to step up I mean it really
we teach leadership at all levels man
you know for us you know what I'm saying
we believe in being a star on your road
you know I'm saying whatever your role
is mastiha role be a star a road that's
how you can help us you know a lot of
times in a series before if I'm not
mistaken shame didn't play much in the
Eastern Conference Finals because it was
more physical and that was my yes and
that was Mike that was my time to step
up and hold it for yeah yeah and then
when we got it to the finals with San
Antonio now we go a little smaller we
want to spread the floor gear Brian no
space and that's now it's change time to
step up and hold a fork and people don't
understand man it's part of being a
professional you know Sam it's maybe
only been two years in this league out
of the 17 I've been here that I've had
the road that I wanted the other 15 I
would take a charge of getting knocked
on my ass getting stitched up picked up
rebounding and doing whatever it took
you know what I'm saying so we had guys
that knew what it was about you know
sandy understood what they wrote was and
they made a commitment to master their
role and be a star
to help that team and that's why you
look at the game where what Shane had
and where he shot the ball and everybody
remembers the Mike Miller game with no
shoe and you look at the game that Mario
Chalmers had and a playoff I think one
game he went for 30 or something like
that so you look at those moments that
those guys had and it's because
throughout the season we kept each other
motivated and we understood that hey
your time will come
don't let it down bro and that's what
everybody understood we didn't quite say
it like that was something like that no
no no totally but I mean on that 2016
team the town won a championship
Richard and I sat down with T Liu and he
say hey we're going by matchups so for
me it was like you're splitting time or
Richards some series you're gonna play
10 to 12 the next series you may play 12
to 24 just depends but you got to stay
ready and I think that type of Pro
mentality
helps you support the guy in front of
you because you know they're gonna
support you coming back yeah I mean a
lot of people don't understand man like
when you're in a playoff series like you
don't got time to get your rhythm hey
you know tell me get a feel you got a
time to get a feel and nobody cares if
you played in a series before or not no
nobody cares and you know that feeling
and you can attest to that man you got
to be a professional man you got to be
ready you gotta you and I use this term
of you you probably say it in a
different way stay ready so you ain't
got to get ready man they already see
you ain't got to get ready yeah I mean
there was some series where guys didn't
know if they were gonna play you should
have seen the warm-up isn't that
everybody was drenched the god fifteenth
two because if somebody got you know
think about it didn't people just to
mention my championship game Mo Williams
hadn't played in the last two series he
got in in Game seven and gave us big
bucket it's a good defense and I'm like
the fact that he was ready
you just got get a man credit for
staying ready sitting with Dante Jones
for us for game live and I mean we
wouldn't have won without those guys but
as we're waiting here on D Wade as usual
my man's late technology don't what is
money and what it gets that I think the
fans would want to hear what's like a
good young D Wade story
oh okay so Mandy way was a we were
working out in Miami long we were just
got to Miami we were standing a hotel
downtown called a mutiny hotel and we
were working out every day we had our
routine we working out working out so
you know he was a new kid in town high
draft pick you know I'm just a local kid
I don't know why I really know me but
you know I'm known around the city you
know I'm saying and once again like I
said anyway we really bonded together
you know Sammy was kind of like brothers
early we had a lot of similar things
from our upbringing in our past so one
day he we passing through the lobby and
he gets stopped by this by this lady you
know I'm saying um so you know he's
talking to her you know they just held
on a conversation so he doesn't know who
the lady is but I know who the lady is
so when the lady walks away
sit down lady was ojx wife I said listen
young man I said we taste so let me
taste some D ways yeah I'd say I don't
know what she said to you I said I don't
know what she said to you but this be
the last time you talked to her cuz we
don't want no problem you know I know he
got a man listen man listen and I laugh
about it to this day man cuz it was so
funny is like man you know Oh J woman
who was talking to you what you there we
go
ad finem we're getting ready to watch
these waited 15 minutes for D way to hit
the on button on his computer I know you
don't you listen I know you very well I
cried the first time I open credit is
time damn now you and just the third one
you you'ii cry I mean it was a second
one okay got it okay good okay don't
think about this did you care or was it
blown out of proportion
oh here's my
down I wouldn't went down yeah wouldn't
it but we cared those Artie minute right
my bad Brian my bad Brian I already to
broader brawn to eight to Ray aesthetic
run on a break I'm trigger huh break
what listen let's do that now you know I
can run let's just say you out let it at
him and beat the lob of the court I did
no no no no that was a slow penny you
got it you don't gotta go fast brother
you gotta admit you gotta count that's
all
I never lie yeah man let's do a never
move but a night no but his release was
what quick is hail I hated trying to
close out new bro oh my god I could tell
you that now oh my gosh the Chop played
this showed me his CB I remember this no
I remember the spoke gave them the
option he said I'm going for the win
wait let's run that same pickup row but
we just ran into play before we got it
done he said running again you throw it
back to blow that Chris Bosh to me was
for the hardest guys to guard with Dirk
and Zach Randolph I was like all three
men all of them Oh smells closer all
three on slowest cold syrup and hard to
go hard the guards look at this just so
still is this right oh yeah Jason Terry
okay you do this yeah
what Woody's Bostick games like now that
Ray was on your team did you did you
have like a little bit more fire just
because news are awesome yes I didn't we
didn't need no any beat up in here
before wit Ricky I would like
I'm a tree before we beat that ass wit
ray and then ray came over why you mad
at him anything like it's his fault oh
there we go
ah copy big Jeff great I'm great with
nervous as hell you see the look in his
eyes
Jeff Oh wheeler Jeff is a good dude salt
of the earth when you know when I'm 27th
in game Street when did you feel like
okay this streak is different it wasn't
six it wasn't game ten when did y'all
say okay let's do this let's do this
basically win a game every single day
for a month I think for us like they
start talking about the 33 wins in a row
and we started what we got I left this
see how far we can go and we were coming
back 27 in the four like yeah yeah we
was doing crazy stuff we was doing crazy
stuff coming back now the teams like
Charlotte would be down 20 and it was
crazy yeah I think I was in Phoenix and
we're up 16 what what were y'all
thinking doing this ain't in my
character so I just went along with the
team on this one I know it I know it the
lighting was outfit situations all the
way down to the outfits it was a do a
way of production yeah we brought the
outfits in for everybody and we had a
good time that was the worst practice I
think we've ever had from coach's
standpoint we were so silly eating like
we were laughing the whole practice
coast was I take a little break we watch
the series against San Antonio the
finals there are people who have
questions on a br app so during this
thing I'm gonna kind of randomly just
shoot a magic and one of them is UD how
did it feel to win back-to-back titles I
mean we won our first championship me
and II way was naive enough to think
that we just was gonna keep on winning
and going back and going back and it's
just not the case
you know sanneh so to have opportunity
to win another one and then to go back
to back and win another one again you
know it's amazing feeling and pushing on
the conversation of not very many you
know what I'm saying and you're already
in a conversation not very many to say
that you're the best in the world at
something cuz very many people consider
the best and very few people consider
the best of the world to actually prove
it so now we have the opportunity to be
the best in the world two years in a row
and it's just an amazing feeling but you
know you definitely feel the total of
putting in an end you planet being the
longest ending playing having a shorter
summer and going back at it again so but
everything was worth it you know saying
I'd do it all over again put my body
through it put my mind do everything
here's one last question that will get
into something else look D wait what was
it what was your favorite part about
playing with LeBron I always tell people
what I loved about bran was how he
brought it in the days that no one seen
him how he brought it in practice man
like he did things and practice that
I've never seen before and we and I
would never see again he was just the
unfair guy but like he'd you know what I
say you practice the way you play he
practiced better than the way he played
like but just to see his work ethic you
know I'm saying to see him in the weight
room to see him at the game to see him
before practice to see him in practice
like his work at this is relentless and
you can't you can't take that from him
man like he loves this game so much his
body obviously you know it's built to
last and he goes out there every night
and he gives you what he can and you
gotta appreciate it well I think he does
that because he knows what's on the line
for him like we may win or lose games
he's being compared to the greatest of
all time so that's his motivation so
when he's ready to go to sleep you got
to think who's getting up right now
right do I have a job
unity to become something better than
just a champion can I be a legend can I
be the greatest and to speak of that
during this series he played out of his
mind I think obviously although everyone
did but what was the scouting report
what was your like main focus when it
went into this series with San Antonio
well I think we we knew that we knew
that San Antonio also us we were top
five in scoring we knew that we were we
knew that defensively we were a better
team but we also knew the firepower of
San Antonio right we knew the firepower
for Tim Duncan in the mono Ginobili and
Tony Parker and you know things of that
nature but you know we knew that we were
pretty even all season long even though
we won 66 games as a team all season
long with them so we know it was gonna
be a battle
so we knew we were in during these clips
just let the fans know what you guys are
thinking let them know how your team
rebounded from that crazy loss after
Game one I mean personally obviously you
lose Game one you know I'm saying at
home and I'm saying and now you got an
opportunity to win game two first and
foremost understanding that we're gonna
be tested mentally like the wind said we
understood that you can play the perfect
defensive scheme and do everything right
and they were still gonna score the
Spurs are gonna test you mentally for 48
minutes so that was the first thing that
everybody everybody had to commit to a
48 minute process you know what I'm
saying might not get it done right that
was crazy just to look at the score the
first game y'all lost by for the next
game y'all won by 19 right so just that
bounce-back was crazy making it 1-1 now
this is a 21 year old Kawhi Leonard here
now we all know him but this is where he
really started to understand it and
believe in who he was yeah I agree man
you know what going back UD I think it
would
if we remember and we want to talk about
it in Game six when Kauai missed those
free throws a great you either gonna go
one or two ways you either you either
gonna fade away and that's gonna become
who you are or you gonna come back and
be even better and that next year and we
played them in the finals you could tell
that him missing that key free throw to
allow you know us to be able to win that
championship in a sense right if you
make the free throws we lose but that
drove him and I think that continues to
drive him as a great player that he
never wants to be in that situation
again where he's not ready for their
moment yeah that was crazy because
obviously the big three you guys were so
dominant but to see this one guy with
that you would say a past his prime Tim
dominant and rker but you guys just it
took two or three you guys to slow him
down which is showed how good he was
oh-oh be me you see me hey listen I need
a game for a bad boy on the team oh look
at 17 hey listen that's what's crazy
buddy
oh you guys we have to talk about this
what happened
twenty-seven three so let me just say it
and we just put it out there by an NBA
note do you hate chasing people off
screens everybody no D way it tasted
people off screens you know I'm saying
and every now and then you make a
decision I'm gonna give it to you often
so I'm gonna chase them off this screen
right here you know you gave it to us
often I think one thing I'm gonna say
about my boy D way now if this coming
time to get a stock one at the game on
the line now I like all day seven days a
week and twice on Sunday the first
quarter he ain't gonna be hearing really
they're the first quarter defense if the
game started he gonna show it
defensively by 8:15 we call that as
false confidence man listen they thought
they had somewhere in Danny Green we
knew he's not that down we knows the
amount of time we shut that down but me
yeah he had an amazing series obviously
you know soccer than that one because we
weren't prepared for him let's just be
honest he was not what top of our report
he did what a good player does is he
stay ready he waited for his moment and
his moment was very special yeah and hey
is that rain how much time game fixed
the most imp is that the biggest shot
and all of MBA Finals history and my
opinion here yeah and I may be biting me
too yeah I think that's the big boys
shot can you remember a shot that's
bigger than atomy they brought to win
the championship
if Ray Allen misses their salary over
for us that was big wanna get Steph Game
seven the one is the one against all
right we don't remember it like it was
yesterday
I remember like yesterday because they'd
rather pick a road and getting a switch
so they can get stuff on them I saw it
on my stuff right up up his ass yeah
yeah yeah Ray's gonna get to the three
and get it and get his piece in and get
that so we're gonna watch the last
fourth quarter of the last fourth car
we're gonna watch the fourth quarter and
the things that I noticed right and I
got my little notes here is that pop
made a switch and start a DL instead of
Tiago Splitter at the beginning at
fourth quarter did that affect y'all or
did you guys just say screw it whoever's
out there whoever's out there yeah we
went we didn't really worry about who
was out there but the Aldea posed a
threat you know and you wouldn't look at
his body type at that time and be like
played the game of basketball man he's
very smart intelligent ought to use the
body in his height and he did pose the
threat floors he man listen before he
had a couple croissants too many he was
playing point guard for the Atlanta
Hawks and for Phoenix yeah
let me get in perfect fun fact I played
with Dianna France man
I definitely yeah like you say before he
got a couple biscuits in oh right yeah
me Shane
Shane Battier was going nuts this game
Louis a week a shot to do this let me
get that wait so you know you're seeing
the same things that I am during this
time if you watched the first five or
six minutes d-wade really is I would say
almost chilling on offense and the bran
is doing a lot of the scoring is that
what you guys just trying to go at Tim
Duncan over and over and over again
were you trying to get the switch
definitely put two um in rows not warfet
yeah I mean at this time it was it was
it was King James you know mean like it
was he was on a different level and he
was gonna lead us to the championship so
we kind of win as he win honestly and we
all had to play our roles you know and I
even though my role was a high role on
the team I still had a role to play and
it was beneath you know LeBron he was
the first option for so you waited to
your authority and you got to be ready
for it so we have a fan question just to
kind of break this up a little bit cuz
nobody scores until the timeout what was
your first reaction to rain chanting I
felt at that moment that we was gonna
win this championship you know it was it
was fate you know Francona be in a
position and let's go back to that play
right you know we talked about you know
they talked about Tim Duncan not being
in the game
and if you look at it it wasn't about
Tim Duncan not being a game San Antonio
made a defensive mistake they both when
Chris Bosh at the screen they both went
to run and it left Chris Bosh opens able
to go down the lane and grab the rebound
so we know one straight once he grabbed
the rebound it hit ready one straight
hit that shot I just felt like it was it
was meant for us to win this
championship man and and let me tell you
let me tell you something which is rule
of thumb in a game like that off misses
rebound fire really everybody was
surrounded around CB fire drew
yeah strike at the steel going in since
game 7 what was supposed message yeah go
yeah listen and all honesty it takes
nothing away from SPO he was a great
coach man but once we stepped down on
there man we put it in our head if it's
gonna be lost as when we lost with us
you know I'm saying well nothing that
takes nothing away from zero and what
he's going to lead us and be the leader
of our team but we always said our self
that you know if we don't lose it it's
gonna be lost with us and you know Braun
always said look at me
listen to me I'll call the plays Shannon
you know I ain't telling you none you
don't know right no I mom is asking for
the people who aren't in these
situations oh I know it yeah oh dude
beau did his job to get us to this
position he helped us get to game seven
at this point it's not on here no more
this is listen we all know each other
strengths and weaknesses we know each
other plays I mean we tired think about
a chance we had just came off a seven
game series in the Eastern Conference
Finals versus Indiana before this and
now we in another game finals so we're
tired everything this is this is about
heart this is about you know mentally
what can you you know how can you think
about just one last game giving
everything you have yeah nothing to do
with coaching for needed minutes at this
game know if you break this fit I've
watched these this fourth quarter maybe
seven or eight times just to prepare for
this and literally it is like Tim Duncan
is hitting everybody going through the
lane brunch and Battier look at three
people it is a game seven grimy grimy
grimy game but I mean it's there's no
coaching you can't even run a play
because everyone's just grabbing you so
look everyone is almost exhausted every
single play and just but I do give coach
Vaught credit whoever called these plays
coming out of timeouts y'all so much and
I'm a single yeah every single jump
yeah you're right you're sure and drop
something those definitely best
offensive yeah yeah and the same for San
Antonio for the most part they end up
getting good shots and good looks some
of them went in some of them didn't but
they still got good looks I think this
might be the only time G Wade you
actually bring the ball up to court but
then you pass it you know real emotion
dust all over the plate that's the big
big three we the big four you forgot
about Mario guys the big three plus one
that's what we called it oh you know you
were tired
now you gotta see B you better get a
stop couldn't get off video I heard you
guys talking about the big three versus
that little twelve and you think about a
game like this oh who really helps you
in a game like this is you know guys
like James Jones and you deed guys that
was not playing but they see things out
there on the floor that you don't see
and you know it really helped us in time
I was coming to the bench coming to the
sidelines telling us you know different
ways we can attack and different things
we could do so even though they might
not have played we don't win a
championship without you know their
tutelage for sure for sure
I think another person I was telling you
do this it doesn't get enough credit at
all is Chris Bosh if you just watch him
he missed the three from the corner
sprinted back was physical with Tim
Duncan so they can't seal to get easy
layup right and puts Tim Duncan at the
line due to a foul but you're not giving
up a easy layup you make Tim Duncan who
at the end of his career didn't shoot
that well from the free-throw line
you give your team a chance through the
effort place but just screening his
defenses energy even though he didn't
score just that
screen right there it's illegal as hell
but it brah makes a shadow man jump is
what you need Jenny that's amazing right
a lot of people you can say it many many
times a lot of people not remember I
think that Chris Bosh did not score a
point in Game seven but was just as big
as anyone else on that court about
everything he brought into the game he
didn't score but you would think you
need to score to be effective but he
didn't yeah that was a big TV was a huge
biggest piece to the puzzle man like
people always and don't take nothing
away from Braun and D Wade it was be a
fourth it was our two main guys but I
think do you way to tell you like that
huge piece of that puzzle that touch
that puzzle don't work without CB no D
wait there's not one right there ball no
see there's another fan question what
was your guys's best play in Game seven
I know what it was but what was our best
play yeah
it's just a fair question so I know what
the belly hit me was was a tough pass
and I got the layout that was a big
bucket coming out of the timeout I
recall about a huge bucket this is a
wild ant one from Tim Duncan oh my good
we are watching it I mean it's Halloween
fun to me I don't know how to use a
glass every will everywhere this is the
way you're talking right here
you wait this will come down it catches
it almost at the elbow you curl you can
say Butterfree the moderator and the
foul man we know talk about only we're
about it you fall down all the time you
see you see you see that one gotta feed
that back on D boy it means some two
minutes look at the boy got the wheels
this is great defense I took away no yes
he be your liner
you're the same lineup since 834 in the
game so no no time or now I mean no
substitutions where San Antonio was only
5 minutes and 50 seconds so you guys had
to have been exhausted yeah yeah man but
at this point you not even thinking
about that man they just as exhausted as
we are it's just about making sure that
you know you do whatever it takes to
make sure that that internet game that's
your team about a half a point it don't
even matter you you just trying to win a
game so whatever no that would be hand
down man down brah shout out the cut
while with the old-school bridge like I
used to have and I like that though we
need oh we get we're gonna go to pick
and roll okay do it back to Braun that
was a lot of people at that point would
threw the ball back to browning real
only make no no yes
here's where it gets kind of wild on fan
of Tony outside oh they missed off
switch
oh you got lucky brownish a mister
that's the clip where everyone told him
don't shame Battier don't get the ball
let it go out of bounds so we could get
some rest yeah we needed it
oh yeah oh oh go with the eye so anyway
go with it yeah I see yeah I know that's
a big oh I thought it was the other one
get up that's a huge missed first fir
Tim don't tip it out shame without shame
going right
he's mad tim-mah he pissed he know he
should have made that knows what this is
his employee right here the big shot
this shot right here - yeah this is yeah
this is not right here for me what Brian
needed man like yeah mo me man he put it
all the rest
he's clutch you know a lot of people
like talking about him not being clutch
I don't know where to get their from but
that's the clutch shot and everyone the
finals was right there that was it yeah
man Tim Duncan knew that that layup what
was needed now here is the biggest I
think the biggest play of the whole game
even down for if you give yourself a
chance make it to it's a one-possession
game right I think this is where they
run this yeah let's fake it but see
defensively you go this huge huge lawn
and if they do it the whole yeah not
ever I don't remember that play yeah
yeah yeah he handed it off and we
switched it yeah yeah but well with this
lineup I was just going to say I think
we started switching everything on the
ball with that liner that's the line
that we was with you he's at the five
not you only only on the ball we never
switched off the ball we switched
everything on the ball one through five
with CB in Atlanta yeah so it just
worked like you can get a bucket off
that for a lot of teams because a lot of
teams don't practice switching off a
handoff right yeah we talked about note
oh it's like listen are we switching
everything like you know you gotta you
gotta get it are we switching everything
no matter what and we made sure of it
very tedious so listen let's talk about
these free throws right here for twenty
four seconds ago he nails both of them I
don't think what she's making right here
they just we just want it we just want
Game six with them coming back so you
know at that we thought listen we gotta
get a stop right now and if they hit
that three then it's so you know it's a
one-possession game so once we had to
get down to court we got the rebound at
this moment right here you start setting
celebrations going on you start filling
it and it's like yo you you feel that
you're about to become a champion at
this moment but I gotta go member wardie
to know yeah what do you remember what
he said in that little probably finish
it oh I told you you weren't that
aggressive offensively tonight you were
actually I had 20 more physical maybe 23
for Shane being the world's biggest piss
man big guys hey Shane wrong big guys
cannot stay sane man listen it's funny
to hear about all the guys that never
shook hands
after losing or winning championships
yet the first thing y'all do is go over
to Tim Duncan and Manu Ginobili and Tony
Parker do you guys usually shake hands
after winning or losing Championships
Championships yeah regular games unless
you my friend I ain't talking to you
yeah we we lost the Dallas in 2011 we uh
we shook hands and even though it hurt
and you're not saying you wanted to but
you gotta just get see in our area
sister it was a respecting we as I
listen you had a hard-fought battle the
team won respect man but it hurt we want
to locker room and we shed a lot of
tears but we had to sort of respect on
our way out yeah yeah well anyways I got
a couple questions for you and one is
from our boy Adam left Co what was how
wild was Birdman at parties
that question before me - go man I must
say this people think burger crazy my
bird got does Braden even dream very
didn't even drink you know what I'm
saying so like when bird got to us like
he was straight narrow like people
understand like you know yeah I've been
through a few times so right now ain't
no saying he making sure he's staying
the league you know I'm saying sofa bird
it was bigger than just basketball you
know saying it was a it was a
resurrection in his career yeah you've
got a houseboat now that's what my gate
man somebody call it at my gate that's
what a gate just for the gig yes for the
game
we ain't any when you live in a compound
like you D lives in let's put a gate Oh
where's he live Pensacola
you got the whole ranches you got the
whole block you got the whole block in
the ranches alright so here we go we got
three or four more questions for y'all
where do you think the big three he'd
stand among the best of all time now
this is a great question because it's
been a lot of those conversations going
on so I want to see what you think I got
you little big three wait that's a
little big three what's a little big
three cuz it's been a lot of talk going
on about big threes well I mean I feel
in the four years that we played
together you know are we the best of all
time probably not as much as my video
goes out again are we the best of all
time probably not but we definitely
wanted the top in in a sense of the body
of work that we put in in those four
years but you know are we the best yeah
that's not for me to say but we're
definitely one of the best we had too
many complaints about your face we had a
yeah we can still see you still like
[Laughter]
I've been sitting out thinking about
this I would say they would be second
and all because you would never know but
I won't put them if anybody's on top of
that day big three I would say it'd be
it would be it would be Jordan pepper
and
and and rocked and yeah and I would say
those will be my two I'm not gonna tell
you why I don't pick go to state they
got a great big 3-2 but I'll pick our
big three to pass to go a little bit
past Golden State big three and I would
say our big three was behind Jordan them
I would say we had the second-best big
three that's my opinion but what is that
based on based on just numbers is a
based on ships like what is it based on
is is the argument right because if you
want to base it on team fives Horace
Grant Scotty and Michael was
unbelievable and their three
championships they won together so you
know it's it's hard to always compare
generations and that's what we're gonna
always do but it's hard to compare
that's why I just said listen we're one
of the best big 3s and we're one of the
best teams that's ever played in the NBA
alright last two questions is how often
do you guys wear your championship
excuse me rings I don't wear mine I got
mines in my safe I gave my first one to
my father I got the other two am i safe
you know I'm saying sitting pretty and
they just they just chillin I'm Tom I
don't wear very many rings either got
one right here that's buddy yeah yeah I
don't know what man I need I think I
wore mine for a photo shoot towards the
end of my of my last season but before
that I didn't I didn't bring them out
unless we were having like a team
meeting before the playoffs or something
like that to just look at a member I'm
remind myself of what the goal is the
goal was never have the best staff
individually the goal was always to get
that ring and to get that trophy so I
always looked at I'm gonna playoff start
it to remind myself but I never wore
yeah I don't I just look at money I've
worn it maybe six times total that just
morning you weren't it happy behind my
shirt or your ring he'll be where I was
so tired
[Music]
wait only wears anyway clothing you do
you know why he wears that he wears that
because he can't tell what the body felt
looking like underneath the shirt that's
what this conversation again we don't
have to love him this conversation again
man
no no now listen look we're all in the
process of giving latex leave them
together we plant in Cleveland every
year this is what we owe the whole time
see hope the entire time
man listen and that was one funnest half
of seasons I've ever had even we want 20
in a row running one play and got traded
get up out of here you just want to say
what's up - yo D wait oh man I couldn't
even see my brother oh no he said to his
[ __ ] n and fry it whales say you want
to say was bad yeah want to say what's
up to the fish man oh yeah listen nobody
came by Most Improved I got it favorite
moment as a teammate my favorite moment
has a teammate yeah I probably did not
we won the first championship we had to
cut the food in that first Chechen war
yeah that first one
watching you D cry was like I'm not
saying it I'm not just not cracking a
joke watching him get emotional let me
sit in watching him get emotional for me
that was one of the like I always carry
that moment with me because that let me
know how much you really meant you know
I mean like because this is one of the
toughest guys I've been around and and
when I turned around and saw him being
emotional I realized how much it meant
for the city of Miami you know and it's
not where I'm from
but it became a home and when I see him
that emotionally this is huge and that's
my that's my it's my favorite memory of
UD and if my favorite memory of when the
championships was that exact moment yeah
definitely definitely right off what he
said piggyback off what he said the
first one was like the best for me
because it was the first time in my life
I had allowed myself to take the armor
off and just be in the moment whatever
moment that was whatever I was feeling I
just allowed myself to go with that you
know I'm saying for most of my life I
just been guarded and controlling my
feelings how I feel and how I wanted yet
at that moment I just let myself be in
that moment and feel whatever I was
feeling damn that's crazy well thanks
man we're done thanks everyone for
coming out and watching this has been
great
I didn't play from a me but I feel like
I'll farther team after watching all
this and hearing these stories we can
use your clip where we can use that clip
you made if we double use that cut
hey listen I realize right you got old
man you can still clip it you can still
clip it I know you can you absolutely
right and what's it up yesterday's press
man I will see y'all later
see you guys
[Music]
[Music]